pues vamos a dar paso entonces al
análisis al debate de lo que dijeron
esta noche los candidatos aspirantes a
llegar a la casa blanca o en el caso de
trompa permanecer en ella comienzo con
giovanni en la ciudad de washington
entonces para retomar este este debate y
antes de entrar en los detalles de lo
que dijeron y quiero conocer su panorama
general de este debate que tenía unas
reglas distintas una dinámica diferente
y había una agenda específica para
desarrollo de temas cuál es su
percepción
muy bien santiago lo primero es que este
es un debate totalmente diferente al que
vimos en la primera ocasión una
conversación mucho más civilizada para
los dos candidatos y aquí no veo un
cambio muy grande en la estrategia el
presidente trump siguió siendo el mismo
y en el caso de mayra vino también con
la misma moderación solo que
probablemente con un poco más de
gallardía de gallardía no de que estaba
tratando de entrar es en cuando sacando
la cabeza al menos para dar un golpe por
pequeño que sea en la zona de peligro la
realidad es que todavía el debate tiene
poca sustancia y fue una gran
oportunidad para los americanos
aprendimos más que lo que habíamos visto
antes pero pudimos entrar más en materia
no argumentos más profundos entonces de
los dos vaivén tuvo más sustancia y el
presidente estuvo tratando siempre de
obviamente de destacar sus logros pero
hablando un poco de cuál sería el futuro
para los eeuu
entonces al final presidente estaba
definiendo aire como un desastre
económico mientras que va a ir en estaba
tratando de darle esperanza al pueblo
como lo hizo obama vamos a ver si esto
al final tendrá un resultado como hemos
dicho en el pasado
no serán definitivos o tan determinantes
ambos candidatos no evitaron acusarse el
uno al otro
hablar de la gestión pasada como
vicepresidente joe biden acusar a donald
trump o de lo he hecho no he hecho a lo
largo de estos cuatro años de este
mandato presidencial
nacho usted en la ciudad de mexico su
percepción general de lo sucedido esta
noche bueno pues es un debate con más
contenido que el primer debate
han dejado de lado un poquito el el show
para centrarse en un aspecto más
temático y de mayor contenido sin
embargo como bien dice giovanni yo veo
que han seguido los dos una estrategia
similar a la que siguieron en el primer
momento en cuanto a sus formas de
comunicación aunque en posicionamiento
de mensajes yo diría que donald trump ha
estado algo por encima al principio del
debate veíamos como you by then trataba
de terminar cada intervención hablando
del presidente no tiene un plan que fue
una frase recurrente o fue o trataba
introducirla como un mensaje recurrente
en el primer debate cuando empezó así
tres primeras intervenciones y dicho
pensaba que iba a continuar haciéndolo
hemos visto que no ha sido así yo decía
en el previo al debate que cuando
quieres posicionar algo tienes varias
opciones o pegas al inicio durante y al
final o solo pegas al final en este caso
solo veo al principio y creo que eso le
hace de restar puntos mientras que
donald trump es prácticamente al final
de cada intervención trata de posicionar
el usted tuvo la oportunidad de hacerlo
y no lo hizo creo que en ese aspecto
ganar donald trump con respecto a las
intervenciones yo las moderadoras y he
visto que pudiera ser algo más laxa algo
más permisiva a la hora
de dar intervenciones a byd en que el
presidente trapo al candidato tramo en
este caso y luego las estrategias muy
diferenciadas mientras donald trama
basado toda su estrategia en primero
posicionar logros y luego acabar con el
ataque personal la by de bailén
utilizada todo lo contrario es utilizado
primero el ataque personal a donald
trump o entraba en ese juego continuaba
con ese engranaje de la cadena para
luego tratar de posicionar lo que ellos
harían o lo que él haría vamos a
incorporar a esta conversación a diana
castañeda la corresponsal de france 24
en la ciudad de washington para conocer
impresiones allí diana buenas noches en
detalles de lo sucedido esta noche de
los temas abordados de la forma en que
manejaron estos candidatos este tipo de
debate impresiones
bueno pues yo creo que este debate se
centró en cuatro temas principales que
dieron básicamente más tiempo y
preguntas para desarrollar sus
plataformas a los dos candidatos como
fueron la pandemia el acceso a salud el
tema de inmigración que por primera vez
fue abordado un poco más en profundidad
al igual que el tema de justicia racial
frente al tema de la pandemia vimos a
bailén con un tono más fuerte
responsabilizando al presidente de
donaldson con la muerte de más de 220
mil personas que han muerto por kobe en
los eeuu y asegurando que un presidente
responsable por estas muertes no merece
ser reelegido también vimos como el
presidente de unalt e incluso aseguró
que saudí era demócrata poniendo de
nuevo bajo cuestionamiento y
credibilidad a las instituciones de
salud y después a este debate sobre la
pandemia se desarrolló se fue yendo un
poco más hacia el acceso en cuidado y
atención en salud en donde vimos como
este debate se centró principalmente en
la injerencia en el papel
tiene el estado en la toma de decisiones
básicas de los ciudadanos cómo elegir un
seguro de salud y por eso bailén
mostraba su posición de tener un vidente
y de tener protecciones para las
personas con preexistencias y como
donación decía que acabaría con obama
quiere pero que daría la opción una
opción más libre a los ciudadanos de
escoger su seguro de salud frente al
tema de inmigración el tema central fue
el de los niños más de 500 niños en la
frontera que fueron separados durante
esta política de inmigración del
presidente de donald trump y que no han
podido ser reubicados con sus padres
porque no encuentran sus padres y este
debate se fue centrando más al acceso al
proceso justo para los inmigrantes
cuando llegan y piden asilo cuando
entran de manera
y legal a través de la frontera y tienen
que ir ante un juez así que este fue uno
de los temas principales que también se
abordó frente a la justicia racial
básicamente donalson dijo que le había
parecido terrible el movimiento de la
clase madre al comienzo pero que él no
era racista y bailén simplemente hizo un
recuento un récord de todas las
opiniones y políticas que ha tenido
donalson frente al tema de justicia
racial y al final vimos también varios
incluso ataques fuertes por parte de los
dos candidatos en el caso de bailén
frente al tema de los impuestos de
donald trump frente a la injerencia de
rusia en los asuntos interiores de los
estados unidos y el golpe de trump como
hablaba sobre esta reunión aparente de
reunión y conversaciones que tuvo la
familia bailén cuando era lugar en
vicepresidente para tener digamos
preferencias y beneficios en materia
comercial lo que hay que ver
de este debate es si esta última
oportunidad que tenían los candidatos o
por lo menos en el caso de hecho le va a
permitir disminuir esa brecha o ese
margen que le lleva el vaivén con más de
10 puntos de digamos d en las encuestas
10 puntos de diferencia y a favor de
baile en frente a donald son no sólo a
nivel nacional sino también le lleva una
gran ventaja en algunos de los estados
claves
ahora pasemos de washington a la ciudad
de miami en el sur de la unión americana
en el estado de la florida allí se
encuentra antoni welsch y nuestro
corresponsal para conocer detalles
impresiones desde allí desde el estado
de la florida un estado sumamente
importante por el enorme voto latino que
tiene un estado decisivo siempre en
estas elecciones presidenciales anthony
adelante
muy buenas noches pues lo cierto es que
había cierto escepticismo por este
debate por parte de la comunidad latina
especialmente porque prácticamente en
esta último intento que vienes en este
último debate pues en la agenda no
estaba previsto ningún tema de interés
para la comunidad latina al menos
aparentemente sí que es verdad que se ha
abordado y de manera bastante profunda
por parte de ambos candidatos pues el
tema del obamacare la reforma sanitaria
y de qué manera pues esos 11 millones de
personas que podían perder
el seguro médico pues esos retos que se
podían enfrentar a partir de ahora pero
sorpresivamente ha entrado en juego un
tema el tema de la inmigración en el que
cuando la moderadora le ha preguntado de
manera bueno le ha insistido en varias
ocasiones es que usted va a hacer señor
presidente para reunir a esos 500 niños
que fueron separados de la frontera él
lo único que ha podido contestar al
respecto ha sido con ataques a la
política de obama y biden de sus
antecesores diciendo que ellos eran los
que habían construido esas aulas muy
polémicas por cierto y en las que se
ponían a los inmigrantes detenidos
sin embargo él no ha dado una respuesta
clara a lo que va a pasar con esos niños
se han limitado a decir que
efectivamente va a cuidar
de esos niños que los otros están
tratando muy bien y se ha dado más
información al al respecto
yo creo que era una buena oportunidad
también para que se explicará qué es lo
que va a hacer en materia inmigratoria a
algo que sí que ha hecho el candidato by
den a diciendo que hay que buscar una
solución para esos 11 millones de
indocumentados que viven en estados
unidos otra cosa muy importante también
es el tema del salario mínimo algo que
se está poniendo muy esos sobre se está
abordando
en todo en toda la nación a este
problema que hay con ahora con la
economía los trabajos y demás y yo creo
que el presidente
tenía también una buena oportunidad para
explicar bien cuál era su plan y
únicamente se ha limitado a decir que
esa reforma para conseguir ese salario
mínimo se tiene que hacer a nivel
estatal algo que bailén está defendiendo
y mucho a lo largo de esta campaña
gracias a antonio por este resumen a
recoger algunos de los puntos tratados a
lo largo de esta noche en conjunto con
diana castañeda también en la ciudad de
washington me concentro ahora entonces
en mis invitados giovanni y nacho para
analizar algunos puntos destacados de
esta noche en lo que nos en los minutos
que nos resta para este análisis el
comienzo con nacho en una oportunidad
aquí grande ya lo decía anthony para joe
biden fue el tema de la migración lanzó
una carta y eso hay una propuesta
interesante y dijo que en los cien
primeros días de llegar a ser presidente
de eeuu
presentaría un proyecto para que 11
millones de indocumentados en eeuu
podrían empezar su camino hacia la
obtención de la ciudadanía
estadounidense esa carta con esas
palabras cae fuerte en la comunidad
hispana que fuerte en los emigrantes que
hay en este país ya lo hablábamos es
importante para la economía de eeuu
tener la la fuerza de los migrantes allí
cómo interpretar ese gran anuncio que
hace él
pues efectivamente es una gran propuesta
primero hay que pensar que una cosa es
presentar el proyecto y otra cosa es que
salga adelante luego hay que ver el
impacto que va a tener el impacto que él
podría tener sobre el voto latino porque
no olvidemos que uno de los aspectos
importantes durante toda la campaña en
los que ha insistido a donald trump es
en el aspecto ideológico metiendo a
bailén dentro de él
o de la esfera comunista y sabemos que
muchos de los inmigrantes que reciben
mucho los migrantes que recibe eeuu
vienen huyendo de regímenes donde han
vivido el socialismo y el comunismo
entonces obviamente es una gran es una
gran carta pero habría que ver hay que
esperar yo creo todos los días a ver qué
impacto que pudiera tener que llevarse a
cabo obviamente es una gran arriesgo
arriesgó mucho país en haciendo ese tipo
de declaraciones en un debate como éste
sí sí para mí sí pero obviamente los
debates también son para arriesgar y
para hacer también grandes anuncios
pueden salir bien y puede salir mal
desde luego si no arriesgas es muy
difícil que ganes entonces también
tienes en determinados momentos que
arriesgar y además necesitaba tener algo
de de impactos
por una sencilla razón porque vemos que
dos estrategias muy diferenciadas en
hacia donde quieren
mandar los rumbos o hacia dónde quieren
encaminar los rumbos del país tanto
trans como by d mientras trump iba más
encaminado hacia el aspecto económico lo
hemos visto en el tema de salud lo hemos
visto en el tema de empleo
en el tema incluso del cómic relacionado
con la salud o en el medio ambiente
vemos como bailén ha centrado todo el
aspecto lo centraba en el aspecto
sanitario en medidas de medio ambiente
en medidas del comité medidas de empleo
y eso puede quedar un poco light o un
poco vacío si no tienes algo que pegue
con con solvencia con determinada fuerza
en alguna de las de los temas en alguno
de los temas que puedas tratar giovanni
veo en las redes sociales mucha
actividad y muchos comentarios en torno
a muchas frases que dijo el presidente
trump que la gente pregunta de dónde
sacan las cifras dice el 99.9 por ciento
de la gente no se contagia de kobe 19
soy la persona menos racista el mundo
cuando atacado en sus discursos a la
comunidad afro y a las mujeres de forma
contundente
también dijo que la ciudad de nueva york
era una ciudad completamente fantasma
tal vez lo fue en el momento del apogeo
de la pandemia allí pero la ciudad poco
a poco ha ido recuperando su vida al
aire libre pese a que ya el invierno
está a la vuelta de
la gran pregunta es el presidente de
trump de dónde saca y se arriesga a
lanzar semejante cantidad de cifras en
un debate sin tener la más mínima
certeza de lo que está diciendo y ya lo
critican en algunos sitios the fuck
check in que no está diciendo la verdad
lo primero que pasa es que debes tener
en cuenta que el presidente tram se
caracteriza por un estilo en el cual no
tiene términos medios no tiene paños
tibios son siempre habla en términos
absolutos y en términos obviamente diría
yo bastante fuertes para él las cosas
son las mejores o son las peores no hay
nada en el medio es blanco o es negro
entonces te das cuenta que también es
una persona que nos ha demostrado que
puede cambiar de opinión varias veces en
dentro de los últimos cinco minutos pero
básicamente aquí lo que pudimos ver fue
una persona o un debate que para mí
desde mi punto de vista bastante parejo
con estos dos candidatos que tuvieron
desempeños bastante decentes y podría
decirte que las personas que son
seguidores dentro van siempre a decir
que este ganó y las que son de baile que
vaivén ganó especie
a aquellos que vean el debate por la
televisión pensarán que fue trump y el
que lo escuchó en la radio o a través de
un podcast dirá que fue by the incluso
las personas que lo lean pensarán algo
distinto lo importante es que todo
comunica en la comunicación política las
acciones y las inacciones también
comunican todo comunica bailén quiso
diferenciarse desde el principio de
trump llegó con su mascarilla puesta
precisamente por una estrategia sabía
que tron iba a llegar fiel a su estilo
sin ella a pesar de que trome es el gran
propagador obviamente en este caso del
virus y era natural que trome empezara
minimizando la crisis económica o
minimizando la crisis evidentemente
sanitaria y maximizando obviamente su
gestión hasta llegar incluso a acariciar
un poco su ego al decir que algunos
líderes internacionales le han
felicitado por su maravillosa gestión y
bailén obviamente vino a hacer todo lo
contrario vino a desnudar la gravedad de
esta crisis que está viviendo eeuu
naturalmente para poner en contexto lo
que entiende que ha sido la falla el
desastre del presidente se rompe por
supuesto no me empieza encontrando un
culpable y ese culpable en este caso es
china yo pienso que el presidente
a su punto de la necesidad de abrir la
economía del país y esto tiene
coherencia con la minimización que él
hace de la crisis del cómic si 9 y
precisamente porque al final él sabe que
la economía se termina es determinante
para las elecciones específicamente
estamos en un contexto en el cual las
encuestas le han dado las espaldas
entonces por lo tanto él necesita como
decía en nuestra compañera panelista
recuperaron por lo menos cerrar esa
brecha y precisamente son de estas
plataformas ciertos escenarios que se
aprovechan para hacer esos anuncios
importantes y en esto quiero rescatar un
poco lo que es lo que hablaban ha hecho
con relación a los a las promesas y los
riesgos que se toman en estas
plataformas en estos debates y es
precisamente eso tradicionalmente
estamos acostumbrados a ver en los
debates que se hagan promesas de esta
magnitud generalmente una pregunta que
no se queda en ningún debate es cuáles
serán las primeras órdenes ejecutivas
que se van a firmar en el primer día así
que no me sorprende que vayan allá de
esa promesa tan grande porque la
realidad es que el prometió que lo iba a
someter esto no significa que se va
aprobar ese proyecto de ley y mucho
menos que va a cobrar
en las cámaras del congreso nacho su
opinión en torno a este esta serie de
comentarios y de frases y de cifras que
ha dado trampa a lo largo de todo el
debate y también
adicionó ahí el comentario de bailén en
torno al fracking que les dice un poco
lo que él ha dicho a lo largo de la
campaña en torno a este tema ya que aún
no confundió en sí lo apoya o no se está
jugando un punto importante y son la
gran cantidad de empleados que hay en
pensilvania que trabajan precisamente en
la industria del fracking pues yo creo
con respecto a las frases y los datos
que lanzaba donald trump pues obviamente
coincido con mi compañero con giovanni
sabemos que la comunicación de donald
trump es a todo o nada que sí que es muy
cambiante pero hay algo que lo
caracteriza más allá de que sea el todo
él no tiene miedo a la crítica no tiene
miedo a quedarse aislado en esa espiral
del silencio no que pudiera existir y
eso es algo que le hace único o que le
hace diferente al resto de candidatos
al candidato baile porque además sabe
que tiene un núcleo de seguidores que
los va a seguir diga lo que diga y haga
lo que haga no creo que cuando está
lanzando esas cifras no van tan
dirigidas a
votante que pudiera estar todavía
pensando si me voy por trans y me voy
por bardem o no me voy por ninguno creo
que esas son de de alineamiento para ese
sector más polarizado de sus votantes y
con respecto a y con respecto a joe
biden en el tema del fracking
efectivamente yo creo que ha perdido una
oportunidad clarísima de posicionarse
sobre todo en un estado tan importante
como es pensilvania un estado industrial
que tiene 13 millones de habitantes
aproximadamente 14 millones y que
obviamente es importantísimo para pues
para la elección del presidente claro
igualmente tendremos que esperar me
quedan pocos minutos para terminar este
análisis mañana en las tapas de todos
los diarios las revistas y el tema
comentado en los medios de comunicación
va a ser este debate y quién ganó y
quién perdió que funcionó y que falló un
poco lo que hemos hecho acá la pregunta
del millón entonces giovanni para su
conclusión quién ganó
yo pienso que quien ganó es el pueblo de
los eeuu definitivamente podemos ver a
mayor profundidad cuáles son las
perspectivas cuáles son las propuestas y
más argumentos que lo que habíamos visto
en el primer debate en cuanto al
enfrentamiento de los dos candidatos
entiendo que estuvo parejo como
mencionaba anteriormente el presidente
trump tuvo su mensaje bastante claro y
precisamente en algunos temas no vimos
ningún cambio por ejemplo el caso del
cambio climático tromp respondió de la
misma manera que lo hace siempre
utilizando los conceptos básicos de
cambio climático que él conoce limitamos
a decir que quiere aire limpio agua
limpia y no pudiendo elaborar más en los
argumentos de su respuesta pero
terminando nuevamente con lo mismo
quiero aire limpio quiero quiero agua
limpia yo entiendo que aquí el ganador
fue el pueblo de los eeuu y como había
mencionado anteriormente los seguidores
de bailén van a decir que bailen ganó
los seguidores de tromba es y que pongan
do sin embargo las redes sociales
también tienen otro elemento un
componente importante que muchas veces
se hacen muchas encuestas en las redes
sociales y éstas muchas veces también
tienen un resultado totalmente diferente
fue una gran oportunidad que tuvo los
estados unidos de ser más de eso
precisamente es tenemos el gran ganador
tachó su conclusión quién ganó
bueno yo creo que yo he sido muy neutral
se pueden hacer varias mediciones y si
vemos para mí quien lo haya escuchado
por la radio creo que por el manejo de
voz ya no habrá quien no haya visto por
la tele
aquí hay televisión aquí hay también
varias cosas que se podrían ver en
comunicación no verbal por lo general
trump es más efusivo si te gusta una
comunicación más efusiva más enfática
más pasional podrías decir que gana
donald trump sin embargo es curioso el
buen manejo de cámaras que biden tienen
él sabe cuándo quiere posicionar un
determinado mensaje mira a la cámara
fijamente es como si estuviese entrando
en tu casa y te estuviese mirando a los
ojos cosa cosa que donald trump no hacía
él siempre miraba a la presentadora no
entonces nancho en ese punto pudieran
estar han hecho es cortar porque tengo
que cerrar ya el programa gracias a los
dos por habernos acompañado en este
análisis en este debate a los dos muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros y
ustedes también muchas gracias por la
sintonía gracias